ladies and gentlemen Sharon Stone
the Job Description might read something
like this wanted person of great
imagination with intimate knowledge of
clothing from every period in history
must know how to cut so drape fabric
design and sketch for dozens of actors
create worlds that may not exist and
produce on budget the garments uniforms
and look for an entire film the
faint-hearted need not apply
the title is costume designer but the
job goes way beyond that title this year
the following artists have been
recognized for bringing their
exceptional skills to these films the
wealth and elegance of New York society
in the late 1800s inspired nominee
Gabriella fest Gucci's designs for the
age of innocence conquering four
centuries of storytelling nominees Sandy
Powell recreated the glorious elegance
of Europe's rich fashion history in
Orlando the wild terrain of New Zealand
in the 19th century provided a stark
contrast to nominee Janet Patterson's
authentic costuming in the piano the
prim and proper elegance of England in
the 1930s was captured by nominees Jenny
Beavan
and John bright in the remains of the
day at war time Europe was a setting for
nominee and a Shepards designs for the
heroic story of Schindler's List
and the Oscar goes to Gabriella Pascucci
for the age of innocence
Thanks I am very proud of Ariana ray
thanks him to Marty Scorsese Andy the
producer Barbara Davina thanks - Torelli
costume and Barbara matera thanks
everybody that helped me in my work
thanks my assistant thanks
see at the next audition shine
now you know we go for a lot of same
parts because now we'll be splitting
them amongst Anna Paquin